[Music]
okay 1476 so we got a
pretty serious opponent
all right so d4 we continue
uh to play queen's gambit declined
much to people's disappointment but
nonetheless i think it's
it's gonna be our gateway into
uh into more interesting openings now in
this position i'm gonna introduce you
guys to an interesting little move or
trick
um
it's sometimes good to start with the
move bishop e7 that's another very
andrew tang plays it like this
of course this prevents bishop g5 i mean
it it's an interesting little move order
and if white goes knight f3 then you can
go knight f6 and you avoid certain
annoying lines of the queen's camera
okay so c takes d5 is the other line of
bishop f4 that's the other
uh the other way to play this
the munchback thank you for the prime
okay so knight f3 is is of course a
completely viable move
now here you can
you can play knight f6
and that's totally uh
totally valid but the way that you know
the cool people play
is that they'll
they'll place c6 here
and then reposition the bishop from e7
to d6
it looks like it wastes a lot of tempe
but it's it's the setup that a lot of uh
good players in this position try to
adopt and often times bishop f4 is going
to be played and then we play bishop d6
and offer the trade of dark squared
bishops which
uh is supposed to be good for black in
this position just because the bishop
can sometimes
in such positions be
uh just a little bit awkward it often
doesn't have a good parking spot it's
just sort of chilling on e7
and there we go bishop v6 this is the
main line
now you guys might be looking this and
saying okay i get the idea but you're
not developing any of your pieces how
can you expect to get away with that and
again it all has to do with the state of
the center because we're so solid right
we have a pawn chain the center is
relatively closed white's not going to
play e4 anytime soon because white's
king is also in the center so we can
afford to make two or three moves with
the same piece
don't be obsessed with that rule look at
the position and you can often determine
intuitively whether you can get away
with
this kind of play or not
all right
what if bishop g5 yeah then we can play
knight e7
we can play that we can we can play 97
here and or or well knight f6 is again
not in the spirit of the position all
right so between 66.
and oftentimes this bishop is now
positioned on f5
in fact that's the move we're going to
play and you'll see in this line
positions with two knights against two
knights which is not so common where
both pairs of bishops have been traded
but you'll see it in this line
and that's always a very i was going to
say material imbalance but it's actually
a balance so
why are we going bishop f5 before
developing the knights because if we
allow white to put the bishop on d3 then
we will no longer have the opportunity
to go bishop f5
we could also go bishop g4 absolutely
viable
uh developing move as well
but one that is often overrated by
players and i'll show you guys why
bishop g4 is slightly inaccurate in this
position after the game
no no e3 is fine i mean this is fine for
white it's not a mistake it's just i
mean black is equalized that doesn't
mean white has made any mistakes it's
just white has not played this in the
most ambitious way
no uh we are not trying to play b6 c5
here we are keeping this pawn chain if
we go b65 white's gonna take it and
we're only bringing trouble to ourselves
because we're gonna be weakening the d5
square this is not the position where
you want to go for that plan
our our subsequent moves are going to be
to develop both knights knight d7 knight
f6 castle maybe get one of the knights
to e4
and i realize this position is quite
boring but you have to know how to play
these types of positions in order to
transition to more complex ones in my
opinion
and that's the premise of the speedrun
it's not always going to be the most
interesting games but hopefully they'll
always be instructive
okay so small subtlety i like to play
knight t7 before knight f6 because
if we play knight f6 first perhaps we're
allowing knight e5 so let's prevent
knight e5
and then develop the other knight to f6
we have a question about queen b3 b3 you
can play rogue b8
no problem queen b3 rook b8
and then remember you might be like well
wait a second then the the rook's tied
down to defending the pawn but
the queen is tied down to attacking the
pawn right
you're very happy to keep the queen
occupied like that
okay so knight knight f6
so far so good we've solved our opening
problems
position is very comfortable
and um
after we castle
everything's going to be in in its
proper place
so far
white has not done anything
terribly wrong i mean again he has not
played this very ambitiously but of
course look at white's position there's
no targets white is very solid
yeah so as i said after queen b3 i think
we're going to go rook b8 i i don't love
the move b6 in general in such positions
because it softens up the the c6 square
why create an extra target for for white
unless you're playing c5 which as i
explained we're not really doing at the
moment
we can also throw an h6 aimed against
knight h4 in
london style yeah
what would i do with white well white's
got the classic minority attack a3 b4 b5
that would be one thing i would consider
um but it's yeah that's the the reason
that we've solved our opening prompts
not so easy for white to find a good
plan here
i would consider going knight h4
actually that's not a move that that's
in the purview of most you know 1400
players
okay yeah it is crazy to castle queen's
head and i'll explain why after the game
not entirely crazy but
it's inadvisable i'll put it that way
queen d2 okay
yeah there is einsteiny
uh i'll explain that as well
one second
okay
so first of all i don't want to rush
with 94
because okay 94 we're gonna have maybe
we do because if if 94 knight takes e4 i
want to take with a pawn and that's a
typical
typical um
kind of motif in these positions to take
with a pawn and then open up the d5
square for the other knights i think you
guys have probably seen this before yeah
we can play rook fea we can play
something neutral
uh let's start with rook fer8 and then
let's see
how whether we want to play 95 94 maybe
on the next move
so
you can see that he's spending a lot of
time here
not really able to generate a good plan
is it okay to trade your bishop if he
goes knight h4 yeah i mean knight h4
bishop g6 is fine but i would prefer to
keep the bishop so we might go bishop e6
and then you might say well we got our
bishop
away from its most active square but
also the knight on h4 is
quite awkward so it's a
double-sided if you will
well a3 we can go a5 so it's not even
easy for white to organize b4 and rook
b1 is impossible because we have a
bishop on f5 so what i would probably do
with white is go knight h4
bishop e6 and then rook ab1 to try to
prepare the minority attack
yeah or maybe bishop d3
even though it loses the tempo that's
not a movie's likely to play
because he's already played bishop e2
rook e1
rookie one is neither good nor bad it
doesn't really do anything whereas
rookie eight occupies more squares
but there's a pawn on e3 so for him to
put a rook anyone is not as sensible
though he does it
and i think now is the perfect time for
knight e4
now is the perfect time for 94 because
after knight takes e4 pawn takes e4
the knight can no longer drop back to e1
the knight has problems you might have
to go like this
that's obviously passive
or like this and then the knight on h4
is going to kind of be trapped there
so
it's starting to get just a little bit
unpleasant for white i i don't think
black is significantly better but
definitely slight slightly better okay
we've got multiple approaches in a
position like this we can play very
positionally
and the positional approach would be
would entail getting a knight to d5
knight f6 or knight b6
and then knight d5 just putting it on
that semi-outpost
um i don't like the move c5 here because
then white's going to go rook a to d1 we
don't want to open up the center
because we've got more to gain from the
center being closed
yeah knight f1 hg3 is a very high level
idea here
but we can also take a more aggressive
stance and play a move like queen g6 and
start
creating threats against the king
[Music]
let me think about this for a second we
can also lift our rook through e6 to g6
but the funny thing is after rookie six
white can play knight f1 very strong
move
and meet rook g6 with knight g3 closing
down the g file
so
we can also take a
middle ground approach and go queen g6
king h1 and then knight f6 knight t5
or we could go rookie six and after
knight f1 we could go rook h6
and try to get the rook onto that square
um but i i want to play positionally in
the speed run i i don't want us to rush
any attacking ideas until we've
fully cemented our advantage this is not
going to go anywhere we'll have this
later too
let's start by getting our knight to d5
and
a lot of people view this kind of
patient play as being lame like i wanted
to attack
but this put yourself in your opponent's
shoes this makes it incredibly hard for
white to
just to breathe and probably knight v6
was more accurate because it prevented
bishop c4
the trade of bishop for knight is
probably good for black though because
it leaves him just with this very very
passive knight and our bishop
is quite nice here it can sacrifice
itself on h3 later it's not a bad bishop
at all
yeah knight f1 knight g3 is an idea on
the rye lopez and the juco piano but
it's that here the knight is coming from
a completely different direction
well
if there was an if there was a way to
know when the attack wouldn't work then
there wouldn't be any failed
attacks all right rook c1
and
we can complete our maneuver with 95.
and notice how
this is holding the c file completely so
that rook is also pretty much useless
though i would consider going rxt5 here
and at least trying to create some
activity
what's the knight doing on d5 yeah
that's a
hard question answer it's not that it's
doing something specific it's just
occupying a central square and exerting
control over
a lot of squares on the board for
example it's preventing b4
and also you never know when the knight
can jump out to f4
so it's a good idea to think of pieces
as okay what is the piece doing here but
you shouldn't limit yourself in that way
a3
all right so clearly b4 is being
prepared
and
kind of automatic response here is a5
now if i were white i would i would go
b4 i would consider going b4 anyway
that's a difficult move to play though
that's that's not a move which a lot of
people will come up with here
and i'll
explain the lines after the game
right
and sometimes an 800 makes a gm move
so again queen g6 i think you guys are
over overestimating it because queen g6
king h1 queen g6 is sort of one move
itis
it creates a one move threat and that's
all it does rook c2
okay so i've talked about this before
but
let's begin by permanently preventing
white from playing b4
how can we do that we can make a move
here that essentially
for all of eternity will prevent white
from going before
yeah we can play the move a4 but
i'm going to amend what i just said a
little bit we're not in a rush to play
a4 because now b4 is not even close to
being a threat we can play a takes
before and the rook on a1 is going to
hang
so let's begin by getting a rook to g6
finally
and
when
the time comes we can always play a4 and
meet b4 with on passant which totally
takes the sting out of it
okay yeah he can play rook c5 and then
and then we're going to play a4 because
that attacks the bomb
bishop g4 good move very good move
um
this forces the bishop train and it
leaves us with a night versus night
situation where of course our night is
going to be a lot better than white's
night
but this is nice
okay we trade and the night comes back
into the game
okay so let me think about this for a
second how do we want to play this
there's many ways we can do this
but i like one in particular
f5 unfortunately does not force him back
this is a very common mistake f5 allows
95 and we certainly do not want to give
away
an outpost a counter outpost on e5
don't forget that you know the knight
isn't automatically going to move
backwards in fact
in order to push the knight backwards we
have to do it in a very careful fashion
if we go h5 we still allow knight e5
and in that position if we go f6 the
knight re-routes to c4
where i have to say it's positioned
quite sensibly
so what we can do is play f6 first
and then h5 and then the knight s is
pushed back to h2 and then we can play
f5 and open up the flood gates to g6
oh it's this weird it's a little bit
slow but it's not like white is doing
too much on the other side of the board
so we can afford this
so first we play f6 to prevent knight e5
shut out that shut off that valve
then we play h5
to chase the knight back to h2 and
because the move f6 had the drawback of
blocking
the pieces along the the sixth rank
then we push the f pawn forward and we
can even push it to f4 okay he does the
he does our work for us great
uh now we can certainly we can play f5
without playing h5 which is even better
okay now he's getting trying to get the
knight to g3 which is going to be a
little bit too late
all right
so
how do we want to continue the pressure
many ways that we can proceed here
um first of all we can play rook f8 we
can get this rook into the game and
prepare f4 okay the most traditional
plan in such positions is to prepare f4
we can play f4 immediately
we can play out four media but i like
putting a rook behind a pawn like that
now of course rook recap 8 gives up the
pawn on a5 which in one of my over the
board games i probably would not fear
but in the context of the speedrun let's
begin by playing a4
just so that we're not giving any
counter play
he's probably gonna go knight g3 and
then we're gonna go rook f8 and try to
push f4
and there's never
a an algorithm for determining when you
care about such a pawn sometimes you
might sacrifice this pawn and checkmate
your opponent sometimes you might sack
upon like this and the attack fails and
you get into some endgame and you're
upon down
and then you're asking you're thinking
to yourself why would i just not play a
move like this
well maybe if you play a move like this
then you give your opponent longer to
mount a defense
yeah rook g6 is good
rook f8 f4 any any attacking move on the
king's side is essentially good he's
down to a minute also on the clock
yeah rook g6 is great or g6 there's
knight g3 though so i wouldn't be too
in love with that move
or g6 there's knight g3 closing down the
g file
i wouldn't go crazy for rook g6 rook ac1
yeah aimless
and now we can complete
us you know continue assembling our
pieces on the king side we're about to
play a foreign breakthrough
and guess what then the knight could
maneuver to d3
f4 is coming
white could play g3 and we might even
still play f4 and just sack everything
and open the king up
yeah he might have to play g3 but g3 is
just so weakening we can also play h5 h4
there
yeah we certainly don't want to go b5
that that that gives purpose to white
strokes exactly okay so knight h2
f4 probably he wants to meet with knight
g4
okay
so what comes to mind if we want to play
very prophylactically we want to prevent
everything
yeah we go h5
and f4 again the same idea one of the
pawns stops
the knight the other pawn does the
the pushing
and now f4 finally we're ready he takes
f4 and guess what this knight on d5 is
it has waited so patiently this whole
time and now a knight is
the hero of the attack because now rook
g6 is gonna be
pretty much totally devastating
something is going to collapse here no
doubt about that maybe even knight t3
here
something is going to something is going
to give
something is going to give
okay
so let's not rush because
rook g6 would be an impulse
oh my goodness but we have a beautiful
sequence there actually wait let me
think about this
wow we have a very very pretty way to
transform our advantage
um
in case if if after rook g6 white plays
rook g3 yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna go for
it
i probably would have gone knight d3 to
slice the rook away off of the the third
rank and to attack the d4 pawn yes
okay so what do i see here well there's
no fork on e2 immediately but i think
you guys are already seeing
essentially the start of this tactic
yeah we begin by taking
this is classic transformation of the
advantage right
we positional domination now turns into
a material advantage queen takes d4
check
but we're not just winning a pawn i
wouldn't go for this if we won just upon
we're winning two pawns this is what
makes this really pretty
this is
a very typical pattern but here we have
something really nice what am i talking
about so don't take the rook quickly
because then knight takes f1
if you think about this yeah we can play
knight takes g3 then come back to e2
and only then we can take the queen
we can also take the rook first yeah i
mean taking the rook first makes a lot
of sense
because why not trade more pieces when
we're up two pawns
nice and now we're up two pawns in the
night end game is completely winning all
we have to do is bring our king to the
center
and
push the e pawn push our pawn majority
it really doesn't matter we can win this
in many different ways
okay so if we want to be if we want to
be like super super clinical here
although
i mean i would start by playing b5 and
just uh
you know essentially preparing our queen
side pawns to to be pushed
okay so
again you don't it doesn't really matter
even what you do here you can take on g4
you can play h4
i like i like keeping pawns on the board
when possible so i like a move like h4
it also stops the king from coming to g3
and we can always support that pawn with
g5 and if y plays g5 then white's gonna
have a weakness on g5
and
we can win this in 800 different ways we
can bring the king here we can put play
c5 before
okay so in such positions the least
risky approach is to keep your king in
the center
so that in case something happens and
white infiltrates you can always use
your king as a a last
method of resort so what i would do is
try to use this knight to win the h3
pawn which is of course white's biggest
weakness yeah a lot of you are
indicating this knight f3 and then
either knight g5 or knight g1 doesn't
matter
and probably no it does matter knight g1
is more accurate because knight g1 is
actually much more accurate because
then if he goes knight f5 we can go g5
and we don't have to give away the h1
yeah knight f5 g5 so that's very
important actually and kudos to our
opponent he's trying trying everything
he can
there comes a point in such end games
when you have to stop caring about pawns
like here i made a mental judgment and
i'm like he's gonna go here and here and
here we're gonna let him take all of
these pawns because i know that i'm
gonna promote one of my puns i just know
that even without calculation
i mean
there's nothing to calculate here just
going to h3h2 e32
whatever
that was nice okay we can go king f4
also
yeah so you can go e3 here you can
promote
you can go king f4 and chase the knight
away like that approach
okay take it
move the knight back and then make a
queen make another queen
again don't pre-move in these positions
because this is not stalemate but it's
close
this is not stalemate it's a check
and now
okay checkmate
again it's easy to stalemate in a
position like this
i'm looking for maiden two it's not so
easy to find but oh yeah queen eight
check is
is the mate in two
nice
that was a
satisfying positional game
wow a lot to talk about i've got about
15 minutes
very nice uh and as you can see the
queen's gambit
can allow you to produce these kinds of
games so bishop b7 again a little
subtlety in the opening knight f6 is the
traditional move and then bishop g5
leads to the main line bishop b7 doesn't
allow bishop g5
and if knight f3
as far as i remember
yeah like let me see now most here here
you play knight f6 and after bishop g5
white is already committed to putting
that on an f3 which is a little bit of a
commitment
okay
so
[Music]
either way c d e d and now knight f3 is
is a little bit toothless bishop f4 is
the main line
c6
e3 and yeah bishop f5 is
the most popular move but bishop d6
which andrew tang likes to play is also
very popular
trading dark short bishops
yeah after bishop f5 queen b3 is not not
dangerous here you can just go queen b6
in fact here white's main move is g4 and
this leads to some very very sharp
complications anyways you can you can uh
explore this opening on your own using
opening explorer and stuff
okay so knight f3
um c6
and still bishop f4 um
would essentially transpose to the main
line
oh which she plays bishop f4 bishop d6
oh so this is interesting thank you z
capped for the tier one this is
interesting
according to the opening explorer bishop
g5 is is the main move
so vp bombazi you called it
bishop bishop g5 is the main one people
don't like trading bishops
and now the main line continues 97 you
can play knight f6 too but that
is a little bit weird
now queen c2 most people play so you can
see they're trying to stop
uh the bishop from coming to f5
um and now f6 72 games bishop h4 bishop
f5
queen d2
knight t7 e3 and you get this kind of
slightly souped up queen's gambit
decline where the knights are on e7 and
d7 interesting position
uh probably maybe a tiny bit better for
white just because this pawn on f6 is a
little bit awkward but
this is how the main line goes
all right einstein asks what if white
prevents bishop f5 with bishop d3
well he can't
because the moment he goes bishop e3 we
e3 we went bishop f5
so we we get that in there before
he can get his bishop out to d i mean
white can still play bishop d3 in fact
that's the main line in this position
thank you sky at night gifting to
einsteiny
but
here we can either take or we can go
knight e7 kind of trading on our own
terms and it's equal
and it's equal
what's weird about knight f6 well
it's not that it's weird this transposes
to a weird line of the queen's gamma
decline where
the bishop is on d6 in such positions
the bishop belongs on e7 that's the only
only thing that's slightly off about
this position of course you can play
this as well
and it's a self pin well yeah it's a
self pin and you don't want to move your
bishop back to e7 and waste tempe
anyways thank you mavenstar not that
important uh everything is possible here
so it takes takes e3
f5 bishop two so a little bit of a
toothless way of playing this with white
h3 castles
queen d2 queen d2 is also i wouldn't
necessarily put the queen on d2 because
this walks
walks into a potential knight e4
and this is what i'm trying to explain
it's like the 1400s 1500s you'll see
this pretty often it's not like they
make big mistakes in the opening it's
just that
uh you know they'll
they'll play
in kind of a relatively toothless
fashion just kind of making the moves
making the prescribed moves that you
learn
you know early on you know queen d2
rookie one rook d1 but they don't always
make sense in every position so adapting
to new positions is i think a skill that
really starts to take shape around the
time you're 19 1900 2000 it's just not
an easy thing to do you know figuring
out new ideas that you haven't seen
before
um not not today catalyst i i played
probably for about a total of 18 hours
it was yesterday
uh five bucks from dj i'm an alcoholic
your streams have made my road to
recovery easier
i'm very happy to hear that good luck
um
queen d2
rook fv8
um rook fe1 another one of these moves
and now 94 so we decide to
to change the structure here
oh yeah queen b3 what would we have done
against queen b3 okay so again here i
would play rook aba
and as i explained during the game even
though our rook is tied down to the pawn
of b7 so is the queen white's queen is
also not doing anything other than
pressuring that pawn if that makes sense
i don't like to play b6 in such
positions because now he goes rook c1
and white has the ultimate plan
of pressuring the c pawn if we go c5 i
was talking about this as well this
leads to the hanging pawn structure
in a very good version for white because
white instantly develops a lot of
pressure if that makes sense
what if queen b3 rook ba bishop a4 queen
a4 just a6
just a6
and now b4 is no longer dangerous
because we're
controlling the square very nicely white
has to move the queen back and then play
a4 that's a lot of moves
um
okay so queen d2 rook f e eight recovery
one
now we go knight e4
so after knight h4 bishop e6 we would
have been threatening g5 trapping the
knight thank you for equal to sack for
the tier one
and it's not so easy to extricate this
knight from h4
oh yeah i was gonna thank you for
reminding me i even wrote it down and i
didn't i ignored it so if we rewind back
a little bit why didn't we castle queen
side well the simple answer is because
we've damaged our
our pawn structure is good but in the
context of sheltering a king it's not we
have a hook on c6
in fact we're gonna get mated like in
five moves here queen a4 for instance
hit the pawn
and now b4 b5 is so much stronger when
the king is on the queen side in the
meantime we haven't even gotten started
on the other side of the board we only
have to play h6 white is very clearly
much faster and our king is just weaker
it's just a feeling you get you look at
this position you think well just feels
bad for black and i'm not saying you
don't castle queen side in these
positions you often do there are plenty
of lines of the queen's game decline
where you have opposite side castling
it's just that here i don't like doing
it with a pawn on c6
okay so castles queen d2 or cafe if you
won knight e4
knight f6 and as i was explaining i was
i was
going to talk about a minority attack
this b4 b5
and this is the classic classic plan in
carlsbad structures and in many queen's
gamut decline positions
and the carlsbad structure is when
the carlsbad structure
and we already had one of them is that
the traditional carbon spot is c takes
d5 here e takes d5 and this is called
the carlsbad structure
and this is where by the way this is
where black ones play b7 not bishop d6
and this is where the the old school
plan is rook b1 b4 b5 kind of chiseling
away at black poncho this is called the
the traditional minority attack this is
where that term comes from
um
i was going to make a brief detour
into discussing how to deal with the
minority attack now just for context
guys books have been written on the
carlsbad structure i i listened to a
lecture by grand master jan gustafsson
which was about two and a half hours
long only on actually defending against
the minority attack in the carlsbad like
that's how complex this concept is it's
hard to summarize everything in one
one um
you know five minutes or whatever but i
can give it a shot
there is a couple of ways of dealing
with
the carlsbad structure
onedrive is tara i
uninstalled and then reinstalled it
okay so knight h2 back to the game
at f6 like i explained we're getting the
knight to d5
now rookie six
uh a lot of you are falling in love with
this i don't like rookie six here
because we get the rook to g6 now what
the knight gets to g3 in time
okay congrats and all of a sudden black
is experiencing some troubles here
because
if we move the bishop back then we give
up the pawn on e4
so
i wasn't a huge fan of rushing this
okay knight f6 would you consider bishop
takes yeah bishop takes c4 as possible
but i wanted to really show what happens
when the pawn structure is changed like
that
and i i really liked the idea of pushing
the knight away from from f3
so yeah bishop b4 keeps the structure
and black is of course totally fine here
but i think dtak c4 is a better
opportunity
knight f6 knight t5 and
a3 is met with a5 yeah so b4 here i
think would have been a very good chance
to gain counter play
i mean the point is very simple if if
black just
takes everything and then takes the pawn
then at the end of the line
this is such a typical idea why it has
rook b1 and pinning the knight to the
pawn of the sound white's going to win
the pawn back with interest
so
i was thinking about how to deal with
that here
and what i came up with was
perhaps
not taking the rook on a1 but instead
like
for instance knight takes before
immediately
and or or there's another idea which is
to take on a1 and then after night
before rook b1 to go c5 exploiting the
pin against dwight's queen
but
i don't know what happens here queen c3
i guess black plays b6 and keeps the
extra pawn no so i guess i guess black
is better here nonetheless but it would
have been an attempt to muddy things up
thank you oats 1284 gifting to
bagels
so that was an idea and it just speaks
to the fact that you always have to
consider
you know even if your opponent
quote-unquote prevents an idea you have
to consider what happens if you do it
anyway
back to the
back to the game so rook c2
and now rookie six now now we get we get
the rook lift going
there was an interesting detail you
might ask well wait a second how is this
how is the situation changed now that
uh we put the knight on d5 well there is
a a detail here in this position after
rook g6 knight g3 black has an
additional resource
in fact black has several resources
black is a draw if he wants it
what am i thinking of think about how
this knight on d5 could be used
to attack the king side
what additional
opportunity exists we could have done
this without the knight on d5 but it
wasn't as strong
but it wasn't as strong
who sees
an interesting chance rook takes g3 yeah
just rook g3 of g queen g3 it's not
really a sacrifice we already have a
pawn for the exchange and white's going
to lose at least one other pawn i don't
think e3 can be defended we're
threatening bishop takes h3
and at least just visually this looks
very nasty
uh
we could also start with bishop takes h3
and then play rook to here but
i don't think there is more than
perpetual here after king h1 i don't i
don't believe that if we could lift this
rook up quickly
maybe we'd be winning but white wants to
play bishop f1 and involve defender so
you could try knight 93 here maybe black
is winning here as well but
in any case there's multiple
opportunities if white gets the knight
to g3 here
so these this is positional chess right
these subtleties like if you if you go
for this line here then obviously like
in comparison you're not attacking e3
you're only threatening bishop takes it
it's still not bad
but white can move the king aside
um
so you just have to be very aware of
what role your pieces are playing and i
talk a lot about potential energy
kinetic energy well the knight has a lot
of potential energy currently the knight
might not be doing anything but it as
soon as the position opens up a little
bit whether as a result of a
breakthrough or because of a sacrifice
the knight acquires tremendous power
that's why pieces often belong in the
center because they're just inherently
more powerful when they are in the
center
okay so a3 a5 rook c2
now again i don't think white made one
big mistake in this game i think it was
a series of small inaccuracies that
ultimately accumulated and this was
maybe one of the most important
positions in the game when we played f6
uh this is not an easy move to play it's
just not
because it looks awkward ben feingold
laughs at you and
the massive temptation is to chase this
knight away with h5 or f5
this this is prophylaxis right you're
not playing f5 and giving white a free
outpost
you're not playing h5 and letting the
knight get back into civilization on c4
you're starting with f6 and saying i'm
gonna play h5 on the next move
and knight h2 was a panic reaction i
think after f5 already we're probably
close to winning
i would make the move queen e2 here with
white who can explain the idea of this
move
why why would i play queen e2
no idea
the queen's legs got tired yes uh
real mighty turnip got it
the point is after h5 knight h2 the
queen attacks the pawn on h5 and at
least causes some problems for black now
it causes quite
quite a lot of problems for black in
fact because if you just mindlessly play
g6
this often happens now the rook can't
come to g6 now i would still play g6
because now black can play f5 f4 but at
least at least you've created some
weaknesses
no g6 is okay because black's plan here
is to play f5 and then we still have the
f6 square
but that's what i would propose
knight h2 just gives us
the easiest play in history a4
again b4 there's always on passant
and now we bring a rook into the game
and by the way if white would have gone
after our pawn on a4 there's no way we
would have played knight p6 like here
we've already crossed the bridge all of
our pieces are on the king side we would
go for something like this and i can
guarantee you this is essentially
winning here we absolutely do not care
about
about the pawn on a4
okay
a4 is irrelevant at this point because
we're already like so into d and deep
into the attack
h5 stopping knight g4 and preparing f4
and again queen e2 i would play with
white but here we definitely go g6
because this in no way impedes our
attack down the f file
okay rook f1 f4 ef4 knight f4 now maybe
again in the interest of time i won't
uh talk at length about whether white
had more resilient ways to deal with the
attack maybe he did maybe even here g3
was a better option
give up one pawn instead of you know
letting us transition into a winning end
game
but one way we could approach this is to
rear out the knight to d3 and then
simply go after the f2 pawn this is and
h4 is also potentially coming and just
ripping open the king's side so
the position is lost and after rook g3
anytime you have a knight on f4 and this
is a tactic that you should be aware of
it exists in a million different
openings
this con sometimes also with the knight
on b4 i mean just to give you an example
in the baltic i was teaching this to
hafu
in the days of yore
oh sorry no not not cd knight c3 6
knight f3 knight c6 there's a trap here
where white plays e3 then you play
knight b4 and threaten knight c2
and so white can try to give up a pawn
and intercept the bishop after d takes
e495 you guys know where i'm going with
this there's this queen takes d4 ideas
just being aware of these tactical
patterns is important
because they're very transferable to a
lot of different positions and
immediately i saw this idea
so
we we look at the different movers all
right can you play can you play it here
well it doesn't make sense here because
after queen d4 92 king h1 we're going to
lose the rook on g6 at the end of the
line okay so let's take on g3
now it works and now a lot of people
will just pre-move knight takes d4 but
that's where you just have to slow down
on every move of the combination and see
whether you can't throw in an
intermediate move if i tell you that
there's an intermediate move here most
people are going to see knight takes g3
and 92 that's not hard to spot you just
got to keep your eyes open for this kind
of stuff
except trick with no thank you russell
coons for the prime
and that's it now we trade rooks knight
takes d4 the final
uh point i'll make here is if white goes
knight g3
this is not a scary fork because we can
go e3
and the h pawn is is simply untouchable
and one technique in such positions is
to put the pawn on e2 and then chill
because we're two pawns up we're tying
white down completely and we're never
afraid of knight takes e2 at least
maybe we are maybe
maybe we should be a little bit more
careful here because here the king gets
quickly to c4
although no no it's still us boom boom
boom boom
yeah and we make it happen we play b5
and and this is winning event we're
going to push white's king away and then
we're going to start pushing our pawn so
this is still winning but you have to
calculate it
in any case uh 93 king f7 and that's it
the rest of the game is elementary my
dear watson
all right guys
this is where i'm going to end i have a
couple of things to take care of see
everybody later thanks
[Music]